three rounds five minutes each or a good
start from buchi oh but he gets caught
and it's finished size of sakina's head
it's got its own gravitational pull
charges after galani early
looking for a takedown and trying to put
hands
oh galani catches him
round number one
this fight is presented by mr aladdin
where one opens up with a nice leg kick
no check from soriano again the spinning
bandage spinning backfist looking to
finish it he does for the fans here is
stadium to see two of their own and how
they make the transition to mixed
martial arts in terms of
tuffy news experience so far it's been a
very successful one unbeaten in these
three contests
oh and a big right hand means that he's
gonna go on
let's see what the pretty boy juan juan
il from korea brings to manila tonight
kelly's around the balls of his feet
thrusting the jabs early dragon he's
gotta slow down the movement of kwon
juan ill kwon juan l is coming off a
nasty heel hook submission
and the first striker ahmad
cnn went very big on him recently he's
got a great story to tell can he add to
his story tonight in jakarta
xiaomi has really been focused on his
footwork in the stand-up boxing
[Applause]
where a giant southpaw starts the tall
gangly bean poll indian
unorthodox starts
shannon
said he did more sparring in training in
this camp than ever before
[Applause]
[Applause]
these two women open explosively and
there's the takedown from antonia
top position half guard engineer on top
postures up work some ground and pound
now and you see schweissen throw the
hands up trying to control the posture
and as she did that she let her guard
get past now heavy hands
who will advance to the semifinal round
zaghias ladalia in the black edge of
malaysia in new zealand in the white
house
early on the power in the left hand
ebb's got to be careful not to drop his
gloves too low
[Applause]
it's good